[Music]
now the mob the media they're not just
attacking the president as they've done
for the last four years they continue
their non-stop
never-ending rage fulfilled hateful
psychotic rhetoric about the trump
family and the first lady
been nothing but poised professional
courteous over the last four years
that's not stopping the mob from
here's one small sample folks
this week it isn't just the president
who's leaving the white house because
melania trump is also getting ready to
make the transition from first lady to
unnumbered dame
[Music]
you you suck you suck
such colorful characters with their
local expressions let me just first of
all say that i will miss these two
like i miss pms and hot flashes okay
goodbye
don't let the door hit you but the
question is is she as bad as trump
that's what people want to know
um is she uh an active co-conspirator uh
does she
agree with him or is she under duress i
don't know is she afraid of him
not just melania trump and the trump
kids and family
as the albany newspaper the times union
look at this under fire tonight
rightly so after a vicious piece
attacking republican congresswoman elise
stefanik because she and her husband
decided not to have children
like it's any of their business now the
congresswoman and her husband released a
statement said in part the time
times union's decision to publish that
article that mocked us as child
less is new a new low and truly heinous
and wildly inappropriate
shameful statement is not only
inherently sexist also hateful abusive
and heartless
here with the reaction media reporter
for the hill joe koncha along with
former arkansas governor fox news
contributor mike huckabee you're up
early on fox and friends governor i give
you a plus for effort
um okay let me ask you
just in general the trump kids the first
lady
you know elise stefanik really
the whole thing is disgusting but let's
keep in perspective something
when you resort to the kind of hateful
name-calling
and pettiness that we've seen it's
because people deep in their hearts are
jealous of the people they're
trying to tear down they want those
people to be pulled down to the level
which they deep down feel themselves to
be in
melania trump is a lovely lady and she
has been a gracious and graceful first
lady we ought to be grateful to her
and grateful for her elise stefanik a
terrific congresswoman from new york
who's
bold and uh absolutely effective
and the people who criticize the melania
trumps the elise of phonics and all the
other women show
two things one they don't care about
women they're not about
gender they're about hate and two
they're deeply
jealous because they see in others what
they know they can never be themselves
and it reveals a heck of a lot more
about the critic than it does about the
criticized
you know we've watched this for five
years joe
five years and for people like stephen
colbert
who was in a distant third place in late
night
to mock the first lady in the way that
he did with such
hate to the governor's point uh well
well guess what in
in a couple weeks stephen colbert is
going to actually have to find a way to
be a comedian again because he's turned
his show basically into an extension
of cnn or msnbc and serving at the
pleasure of the democratic party now
suddenly with president trump gone so
does the gravy train
for him go and as a result you're going
to see stephen colbert become
irrelevant in an awful hurry look
melania trump was mocked by
the jimmy kimmels of the world you
remember sean for
for having an accent she's an immigrant
so now it's
okay to mock immigrants for their accent
she speaks five languages which is four
more
than kimmel speaks so i found that
pretty interesting she also once had a
kidney procedure
and you had conspiracy theorists posing
as media reporters on cnn
uh openly wondering where is melania
trump
after she literally had a procedure on
her kidney and she was
recovering from something like that so
this first lady
has been treated worse than any first
lady
in modern history by a country mile and
as far as elise stefanik
she's 36 years old at last check in new
york it's not really
that big of a deal or really that much
of a newsworthy item
that if you don't have kids in your
mid-30s while you're pursuing a career
like she is i know in my case and and
with my wife i didn't
i wasn't until i was in my early 40s
until we had our first child obviously
my wife uh much younger looking much
younger as well
uh it can attest to that so this whole
thing as far as elise stefanik is
concerned if there wasn't an r next to
her name
this isn't a story but she's mocked as
childless
at 36 in new york i'm sorry this is why
86 of the american people believe
that the media is biased because they
see this crap and that's what it is
absolute crap shawn well said both of
you thank you
joe thank you mike huckabee